Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. So, exciting stuff's
happening. Game of Thrones has started casting
season six and we have descriptions for a
bunch of characters. Just to put things into
perspective though, they cast about 25 new big
characters for season five so this is like
a fraction of that. What I'm gonna do is just
a breakdown of the names that they list. Most
of them don't have names. Usually whenever shows
cast big characters they try to use fake names
to throw people off. The descriptions for the
characters are solid though, and they point
to some some very big characters from the books
being cast. And the good news is that, Comic-Con
is just a couple weeks away so will do
their yearly casting video and will
find out who at least like six or seven of
these really big people are. Just careful for
spoilers if you haven't finished season five
yet and new round of the giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video. It's just a $20
Amazon gift card. So here we go. Starting with
The Pirate, I already did a Euron Greyjoy video
for this. That's who everyone thinks this
new pirate character is. I know there are a lot of
Ironborn fans out there there were bummed that they
got cut out of Season Five. It seems like even
if they cut out a lot of that plot we will
at least get Euron Greyjoy,  so there'll be a little
bit of Ironborn stuff. If you haven't seen the
video I did I'll put a link in the description,
but moving along. There's a father age 50 to
60's, he's one of the greatest soldiers in
Westeros, humorless martinet, severe and intimidating.
Really the big thing here is that it said
that he is centrally involved in a protagonist
storyline, so the big theory here is that this
is Randall Tarly, this is Samwell's father.
Samwell and Gilly as of the end of Season
Five are on their way to Oldtown, which is
very near Horn Hill where Sam's family's from.
The humorless description just fits Sam's
father to a T the way he described him to
Jon back in Season One. Then there's a couple other
family characters associated with that father.
There's a mother, a son, and a daughter.
And it sounds like they're just casting the rest of Samwell's
family. Samwell's mother is Melissa Florent,
his younger brother is Dickon, remember he
is the one that Samwell's father is supposed
to like more because he's more of a warrior. There
is a sister listed but I don't remember Samwell
ever talking about a sister in the books so
she could be an original creation of the show.
The show adds a lot of original characters.
If you member during Season Five Stannis actually
spoke very highly of Randall Tarly when he
was talking to Samwell even though Sam's father
fought against him. So that tells you what a fierce
warrior he is. So moving along, there's a new priest
that's said to be in his 40s or 50s, a gruff
ex-soldier who found religion, a no-nonsense
rural priest who ministers the poor of the
countryside, he's a salt of the earth man who
has weathered many battles. Even if they change
the name he sounds like septon Meribald from
the books. You know, everybody start your Gravedigger
theory crafting now. No idea what plot he's
going to be associated with in the books.
Maybe Brienne and Podrick; we'll see. If you don't
know who the Gravedigger is, there's just
like this mass fan theory that the Hound is
still alive and living under a different name.
But then we have a priestess in her 20s or
30s, any ethnicity, she is beautiful, intense
and magnetic. There were some casting sides
that were floating around for a new red priestess
in Old Volantis, so that might be who this is.
It doesn't sound like anyone specific from
the books, but just make a mental note that the
show is slowly casting more more people associated
with the Red God. I mean it only makes sense
if the War for the Dawn is end game. We have
to learn more about his religion and we can
only do that through more red priests. Right
now we only know Melisandre and Thoros of
Myr and we haven't seen Thoros in forever.
So moving along then, there's three boys that
look like they might be part of a flashback.
There's a large boy, an actor who's 10 or 12 but
playing seven or eight, described as a clever
boy who seems too large for his age, big and
tall but not fat. Then a 12-year-old boy with
brown hair, blue eyes, he needs to use a northern
accent. That means he's going to be from
the North in the show like the North the Westeros.
He has scenes where he has to spar with a
wooden sword. Then there's a seven-year-old
boy with dark brown hair, a narrow face, and
green eyes. He also has a Northern accent, spars
with a wooden sword, so the best theory is
that this is going to be a Ned Stark flashback
in the godswood of Winterfell. Ned Stark as
a child; they started Season Five with the
Cersei flashback so of course the show is
going to do more flashbacks. Just avoid like
very definite spoilers. I'm gonna avoid talking
about the character that does have this flashback
but if you know who that is just please use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about it. Next
characters; there's two very Dothraki sounding
characters with names that aren't from the books.
They sound like they're going to be part of
this Daenerys story line early in the season.
She just got taken by them in the finale so
of course were going to see a bunch of Dothraki
stuff the first couple of episodes. Then there's
a band of outlaws. They could be someone from
the books, it could be an original creation
of the show. They all have names that
aren't from the books. The leader is named Lachlan
and the description reads that they've turned
on the people in the land they've sworn to protect.
One of them is called Bauer, he's a powerless
servant who's numb to the horror of those
he serves. All of them are supposed to have
Northern English accents. When I think of Northern
English I think of Walder Frey but there are
also a lot of actors that are supposed to
be from Northern Ireland which is where the
North scenes are filmed, so this is probably
happening somewhere in the North. The only
real notable outlaw bands that we've seen on
the show so far are the Brotherhood without
Banners which is you know Thoros of Myr. That
was back during Season Two, and then Locke's
group which was kind of a stand-in for the
Brave Companions. So I don't think that this
new group is either one of those. This next
one is actually really awesome; it sounds like
a flashback character. He's supposed to be
a legendary fighter, a man in his 30s or 40s
who is a great swordsman and a paragon of
knighthood, he carries of famous sword meaning
valyrian sword, the show is seeking a very
impressive swordsman for the role, the best
in Europe, so the actor that they want to cast
needs to be an amazing swordsman. He'll be filming
a week's worth of fighting scenes for the Season
Six role. There's no ethnicity or race
specified. The leading theory right now is
that this is Arthur Dayne in a flashback. His
famous valyrian sword is called Dawn. It's
a two-handed great sword just like Ned Stark's
Ice. Arthur Dayne is one of the few characters
that other characters on the show and in the
books have acknowledged as being a better fighter
than they were. Barristan Selmy calls him out
as a better fighter and if Barristan Selmy
says you're a good fighter that means you're like
Jesus with a sword. To my opinion right now
there are no living Westerosi characters that
meet this description. That's why think it's
another flashback. So here's where it gets
even more interesting. Arthur Dayne died during
Robert's Rebellion at the Tower of Joy. He fell while he was guarding Lyanna Stark but
it was when Ned Stark and Howland Reed came
to rescue her, Howland Reed landed the killing blow.
So the tinfoil theory to this is that we could
get a Tower of Joy flashback. I've already done a video
all about Lyanna Stark that kind of explains
what goes on at the Tower of Joy so I'll put
a link in the description. But basically
Ned Stark and Howland Reed found out Rhaegar Targaryen
was keeping Lyanna Stark at the Tower of Joy,
went to get her, Rhaegar had to leave to join
the war rebellion but he left his closest
friend Arthur Dayne behind to protect her.
Ned referred to him as the finest knight he
ever knew and after he died he took his valyrian
sword, he took Dawn, to Starfall to his sister
Ashara Dayne. One of the early theories for
Jon Snow's parents were that Ned Stark was
his father and Ashara Dayne was his mother.
Ned was just at Starfall to return Arthur
Dayne's sword to his family. I of course back
the R plus L equals J theory of Jon Snow's
parentage but you guys can watch my Lyanna
Stark video and form your own opinions. Moving
along there's a couple more really big characters
they're looking for from Northern Ireland which
is where they film the scenes in the North.
So just more characters from the North. There are
two big lords they're looking for for different
castles. The first is a savage warrior who's
supposed to be huge, like really big so he's
probably going to be Smalljon Umber. His father
is Greatjon Umber who we have seen on the
show. The other lord is supposed to be ruthless
and calculating, a frightening lord that rules
a vassal household with a castle stronghold.
The other big place could be White Harbor so
they could be doing White Harbor and the Last
Hearth which is where house Umber's from. There are a
couple other big places in the North we haven't
seen yet. We haven't seen the Karhold, yet, we
haven't seen Deepwood Motte, so there are a number
places this could be, but I definitely think
the Umbers for that, you know, the giant character
they're looking for. And that's pretty much
it for like the big characters. Obviously like,
that's a lot of people, so we're not going to see
all of those in the Comic-con video, just the biggest
ones. That's about four weeks away. Comic-con is
like the second week in July. I will be there.
I'll get footage of the panel, all that stuff,
so no worries. I haven't done any Comic-Con videos
yet. It's just its not quite close enough, so when we
get closer that I'll start doing previews of
like all the stuff I'm going to be doing while I'm there.
But the characters I'm most excited for, hopefully,
you know, some of these theories pan out, are
Euron Greyjoy, Arthur Dayne, young Ned Stark,
and Samwell's family. Here's my big question for you
guys: if the show is going to be doing Arthur
Dayne in the flashback, do you think that it's
going to tell us something new about Robert's
Rebellion and maybe something to do with Jon
Snow's parentage? Just because this casting
news came kind of suddenly I'm going to move my resurrection
video to Sunday and then I'll do a Q&A just
like you normally do on Monday. So the giveaway
will just stay open until I post I Q&A video.
I'll just remind everyone when I post that next
video. So while you guys wait for all that stuff to post you can click here to learn all about Lyanna Stark's
history and you can click here for my Season
Six predictions. Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys tonight!